qu'est-ce que les Français attendent de
nous première
question que
voulons-nous à quoi
servons-nous l'enjeu est
simple l'urgence est de construire une
France plus
prospère c'est un enjeu économique mais
au-delà c'est aussi un enjeu de
valeur d'ailleurs heureusement
aujourd'hui en France
l'entreprise est reconnue par les
Français pas par le gouvernement mais
par les Français comme une
valeur la prospérité nourrit notre
identité notre
fierté et notre fierté et notre identité
construis la
prospérité je suis triste que la France
décroche avec les
socialistes et pour la prospérité alors
les amis je veux que le printemps des
républicains soit aussi le printemps de
la
liberté je veux alors mobiliser deux
valeurs deux vertus deux objectifs deux
rendez-vous la confiance et
l'audace la confiance n'est plus là les
Français sont déprimés à nous de
démontrer que la politique peut-être
efficace l'esprit de
service la politique modeste qui ne se
mêle pas de tout une politique
déterminée une politique sérieuse une
politique de résultat et quand on n pas
de résultat il faut passer à
d'autres la confiance dans une société
libérée la responsabilité des personnes
la qualité de l'initiative locale
l'autonomie
l'autonomie qui est la véritable clé
d'une réforme scolaire l'autonomie des
établissements bien sûr il faut que
l'efficacité soit au
rendez-vous une gestion sérieuse des
dépenses et des
recettes une baisse des dépenses
indispensable à la baisse de l'impôt
nous l'avons travaillé il y a quelques
mois lors d'une convention de l'UMP nous
avons chiffré nous avons démontré la
réalité la possibilité d'un tel projet
et il faut respecter les règles
respecter les règles en France respecter
les règles en Europe et si la Grèce ne
veut pas respecter les règles et bien
qu'elle sorte de
l'euro je veux une société
libérée d'un état plus économe d'un État
qui entrave moins écrire un nouveau code
du travail plus léger plus efficace
faire que ce soit dans les entreprises
que se décide le temps de travail dire
non à la surtransposition des directives
communautaires et oui à la redéfinition
de notre
état l'audace les amis l'audace à émigré
oui la fortune sourit aux audacieux et C
affaire de destin et de
prospérité rappelons-nous toujours
une société sans risque est une société
sans croissance alors les républicains
nous devons partager expliquer
promouvoir le risque positif le risque
pour le progrès le risque pour avancer
dans notre
pays nous devons accueillir les
pulsations nouvelles de l'économie
l'économie numérique l'économie
collaborative l'autoentrepreneur dans
nos villes dans dans nos banlieux dans
le monde
rural notre société doit être plus
curieuse et mieux accueillante des
progrès scientifiques et lorsque nous
voulons car il le faut poser de
nouvelles règles nous voulons simplifier
plutôt que contreindre alléger les
charges plutôt que les
augmenter alors oui les amis la droite
veut régler et sait régler les problèmes
et quand elle porte le changement pour
nous le changement c'est par le haut
jamais le
niveellement jamais la contrainte en
tout cas jamais
demain alors c'est beaucoup de travail
et je souhaite nous souhaitons que les
républicains ne s'épanouissent pas
seulement dans le débat des personnes
mais surtout que notre épanouissement
que celui des Français se fasse dans la
construction d'un projet volontaire
efficace qui gar que nous le mettions en
œuvre
vraiment être de droite c'est être
ambitieux c'est être optimiste être de
droite c'est regarder le monde avec
lucidité y voir des opportunités
d'épanouissement et de bonheur alors oui
nous rassemblons notre énergie pour une
France plus prospère
oui le printemps des républicains doit
être le printemps de la liberté
vive la
France